so you should know if you're breaking
into data science or you're brand new to
the field that you should know a
programming language like r or python
but what does actually writing good code
look like keep watching we're going to
talk about that i'm richard and this is
richard on data
writing good code is very important so
you're probably going to work in a team
and if your code is slow or hard to read
or whatever it's going to cause other
people problems in fact if you work in
an environment where there are
production requirements you might end up
in a situation where you have to pass
your code onto somebody else and then
they have to rewrite your entire code
and trust me they don't want to do that
and that's not even the worst example if
your code is bad enough you might just
sit on it for a few days and then come
back to it and then you won't even know
what it does now this is not an r versus
python or julia or sql or whatever else
type of video because that's an entirely
separate topic but instead i want to
help provide some guiding tips and
principles that are going to help you
regardless of what programming language
that you're using
most of these having come from just a
little bit of personal experience of my
own but before i do that though please
take a moment to subscribe to my channel
if you haven't already and to smash the
like button and then i'll have links in
the description of this video to my
paypal account as well as to my crypto
wallet addresses all right so first
thing we're going to talk about applies
to pretty much everything inside and
outside of data science and that's
approaching everything with purpose and
intentionality before you start writing
any code for any project you should ask
yourself this script that i'm about to
write what is it for is it to prototype
some idea or an analysis
is it just to play around a little bit
so you can get comfortable with your
data
is it going towards some report or some
app that's eventually going to a
stakeholder or is there a production
requirement you'd be surprised even from
asking yourself this super basic
question how much time you can save
yourself and in fact if you're diving
into a lengthy kind of analysis it may
even be helpful to think through what
the steps of that analysis are before
you start writing any code you have
those steps in front of you and then all
of a sudden you can sort of program to a
plan that's something else that'll help
you keep whatever you're doing aligned
with your purpose then the second tip
i'm going to give is to minimize things
in your code that are inevitably going
to have to be changed whether that's by
you in the future or by somebody else if
they try to run your code your code
should be able to stand by itself and
whether you're running it now or one
year later or you or somebody else is
running it now as best as possible you
want to ensure that the code is going to
work let's give some examples so let's
say it's march 6 of 2022 you're writing
code and you need to reference today's
date well don't just manually hard code
that date use some kind of function
that's going to pull today's date don't
write code that pulls data from like the
desktop on your c drive that way if
somebody else tries to run the code it's
guaranteed not to work that's just a
couple examples but i hope you get the
broader point then my next point here
might seem like common sense to some of
you but you'd be amazed how often you
run into this
and it's to work from top to bottom your
code whether it's in a notebook or a
script should be sequential that is you
start at the top you run the first code
chunk or set of lines of code then the
next then the next all the way to the
end don't write code like this that just
obnoxiously goes off to the right
and certainly don't write code where you
have to declare some variable or some
function all the way at the bottom
then go back to the top or skip around
just to get the script to work then my
next point is just as much for you as
for anybody who's working with or
reading your code and that's to use
descriptive variable and function names
if you're working with multiple data
sets don't just call them data 1 data 2
data three maybe you make a little
subset of data one and call it data one
underscore one
no give it some kind of real name
corresponding to what it is and the same
thing goes for functions let's say
you're writing a function to convert
strings to factors just call it that
just call it convert strings to factors
don't give it some weird acronym like
cstf or something else that's weird that
nobody else will understand what it is
then of course you don't want to get
into the habit of having a whole bunch
of unnamed python scripts and then
before you know it you're working on
untitled 3 version 2 26 in parentheses
dot i p y and b but that's an entirely
separate issue my next tip is also going
to help both you and everybody else out
and that's to use functions in the first
place a good rule of thumb is that if
you find yourself repeating code more
than once you probably want to wrap that
code inside of a function and then just
call that function reason being if you
have a bunch of code that just repeats
itself over and over it's very long and
hard to read and it's hard to look at
earlier code versus later code and
figure out what exactly is different
whereas if you write that code inside of
a function and call that function
instead
then when you're reading that code your
focus is going to be on that function
and what it's doing and the different
arguments to that function and say down
the road you have to make some change to
the process that's going on in that
function
if you wrote the function in the first
place you can just make one change
instead of having to make that change on
multiple different occasions in your
code so it'll save you a ton of time and
it'll make it much less likely that you
make some kind of silly mistakes but
also please don't go overboard with
chaining functions either i can't tell
you how many times i've been reading sql
code and you've got a select from
statement where you're selecting from
another select from statement where on
the inside it's coming from like six
different left joins where
each one is its own select statement and
it's just messy and impossible to read
and this one is sort of related to my
point about working from top to bottom
instead of left to right
granted a language like r makes this a
little bit better because using the pipe
operator from the tidy verse framework
the pipe
separates one line where there's a
function from the next line where
there's a function so
you can read that from top to bottom
but if i'm reading like from left to
right a function inside of a function
inside of a function inside of a bunch
of parentheses
that's really painful now my next tip is
more of one that's going to help you
prevent all kinds of mistakes and errors
and that's to pay close attention to
your data types i'd say if i've written
some kind of function or control
statement then i go to run it and
there's some kind of mistake or error
the number one most common source of the
problem
is some variable is not the data type
that it's expected to be an integer is
coded as a string somehow or a date time
ended up as a factor
just stuff like that and this is
especially a problem if you're doing any
type of modeling activity so if you're
pulling in some data just take a minute
or two up front to make sure that
everything is the data type that it's
supposed to be
this is one of those things that can
save you a ton of time because you may
go into debug what you think is a really
complex problem and it turns out it has
a really simple fix next tip is to
provide adequate documentation and
comments to the code if there's some
other references or scripts that you're
drawing from provide links to those and
just make sure it's obvious as much as
possible where those things live and
then please comment your code even if
you don't think you have to if you don't
i guarantee you'll find yourself in a
position where down the road you don't
even know what your code does it just
makes it a lot easier to understand the
workflow inside your code and it saves
you time too because when you go back to
look at your code later or somebody else
does you can just look at the comment up
above rather than trying to decipher a
big chunk of code and figure out what's
actually going on there tip number nine
is to check for the latest and greatest
packages in order to do the job you're
trying to do now there are packages that
are deserved staples of their respective
languages and probably will be for some
time there's a reason that so many
people use pandas in python or the tidy
verse for r but let's say you're doing
machine learning in r it's just the
first time that you've done it in a few
years you might instinctively go to use
the carrot package you remember using
that from a few years ago
but you totally were unaware that over
those last few years there's been a lot
of development on the tidy models suite
of packages and who knows there's a good
chance those packages will be faster
more readable and give you more options
for the task you're trying to accomplish
so if you're doing a task that you
haven't done in a while even if you
think you know a really good way to do
it
maybe stop and take a half hour or so
first and just research all the
different packages and methods out there
you never know there's a lot of
development in this space all the time
but it really is on us to keep up to
date with it and then my final tip is to
test parts of your code as you go now to
some extent this one does come down to
personal preference with how much or how
little you want to do
but if you're writing 2 000 lines of
code without stopping as you go then
you're hoping that you can run it at the
end and everything will be hunky-dory
you're just asking for trouble if you're
joining datasets check after you're done
that the format and the number of rows
are what you'd expect
and then if you're doing some kind of
for loop with some kind of conditional
clauses in it and that's just some piece
that's in the middle of your bigger code
check to make sure that you didn't
accidentally wipe your entire data set
off by mistake now this is also related
to tip number seven of making sure that
your data types are appropriate but a
really good just easy thing that you can
do as you go is just when you have a new
data object use the describe or info
functions from pandas or equivalently
like the summary or structure functions
from r
the earlier you can sniff out problems
the better off you're going to be so
that covers 10 tips that'll keep you
ahead of the pack in terms of
programming for data science obviously
it's a non-exhaustive list and it is a
little bit general but i think if you
follow these tips whether you're using r
or python or julia or something else
you're going to do quite well so thanks
for watching this video if you enjoyed
it smash the like button
and then let me know in the comments
section down below what are your
favorite programming best practices
want to see me go into more language
specific practices
let me know then i'll see you all in the
not so distant future
until then
richard
on data